where we start with the revival of
concerts tonight downtown las vegas will
be
bustling again thousands of fans of
music are expected for an outdoor event
it's the first major one really since
the pandemic started
hector mejia is live in the downtown las
vegas event center with the story hector
good afternoon
well good afternoon this is the calm
before the storm
dead mouse takes the stage tonight an
earlier production crew up there on
stage
running sound checks right now running
the screen
checks a big deal the downtown las vegas
event center expects about
between eight thousand and ten thousand
people to crowd the space and
vaccination proof or a negative covet
test
will be required for entry and out there
in the distance where you see the
sidewalk that's the registration area
where concert goers can bring their
proof
to speed things up and they actually can
show up at any time
this will be the largest concert crowd
we've seen here in more than a year
tonight mouse kicks off a two weekend
concert series put on by insomniac
one more concert tomorrow so more crowds
tomorrow and again next weekend
insomniac is the company behind the
massive electric daisy carnival that was
supposed to happen today and through the
weekend but got postponed
besides proof of vaccination or a
negative kova test those who are not
fully vaccinated will have to wear a
mask
and it's part of the safety plan that
clark county had to approve
in order for the event to move forward
i don't think the vaccination card is
that crazy an idea i find that very
interesting
i don't know i don't know i think it's
going to how it all plays out and how
they
mandate all the rules all the
entertainment out here last night and it
was just
lovely it was a whole bunch of love it
was you know the people wanted back
so i'll say you give it to him
more concerts are coming back to life
earlier this week fremont street
experience announced
the return of its famous free nightly
music concerts
that's set to begin june 1st so very
soon
at 12 01 a.m so they're not wasting any
time if you live or work in the area
there are some road closures to keep in
mind that includes bridger street and
third street
the sections that are that are directly
next to the event center
reporting from downtown hector mejia 8
news now back to you